today they're digging and digging
filling sandbag after sandbag to try to
protect these beaches
as residents of one port city prepare
for the russian advance the mayor of
another town mariopol pleads for aid
the best wish
of our people was to
stop somehow the war to stop bombing to
stop shelling
but today
and yesterday their best wish is to find
some food and water
the uk announces sanctions on 386
russian politicians but vladimir putin
claims restrictions will make russia
stronger
[Music]
good afternoon russia appears to be
preparing for an assault on the
ukrainian capital after satellite images
showed a 40-mile convoy of tanks troops
and artillery and appears it's
redeploying to surround kiev well that
comes as britain and the united states
warned that moscow may be masking a
possible plan for a chemical attack in
ukraine that's after it claimed without
evidence that the us has been developing
biological weapons in the country the un
security council will meet later to
discuss those allegations which the
white house has dismissed as laughable
well in other developments the city of
denipro was hit overnight and this
morning it's believed to be the next
likely target as russia's southern
offensive moves north two other strikes
near airports in the western cities of
lutsk and ivano frankiewsk were also
reported in the eastern city of kharkiv
the regional governor says a psychiatric
hospital has been hit by a russian
airstrike he said there's no word on the
number of casualties but 330 people were
in the hospital
in the south ukrainian authorities say
1300 civilians are now dead in mariopol
which continues to come under heavy
bombardment and the russian defense
ministry says moscow-backed separatists
have captured the town of volnovaka that
is just north of mariopol
meanwhile the un's nuclear watchdog says
it's now lost all communications with
chernobyl which is under russian control
russia's defence ministry says that it
will open five humanitarian corridors
today to let civilians flee from the
towns of kiev sumi kharkiv chernahiv and
mariapo
well katharina vitozi reports now on the
latest developments
russia hadn't prepared for this
with guns
and anti-tank missiles
ukrainian forces repel an assault
outside of the capital kiev
this firefight was filmed yesterday
[Applause]
for the bombing of maripole this soldier
says
according to british intelligence
unexpected ukrainian ground resistance
is limiting the progress of russia's
forces
the foreign fighters amongst them seen
by russia as western provocation
regarding the gathering mercenaries from
around the world for ukraine we see them
the western sponsors of the ukrainian
regime do not keep it secret they do it
openly disregarding international law
but how long can this resistance hold
out
these satellite pictures taken within
the last 24 hours show what looks like a
reforming of russian military convoys
outside the capital kiev
you can see towed artillery in firing
positions
u.s defense officials say some russian
contingents are just nine miles away
from the capital and that russia is
preparing for a fresh wave of assaults
here and across major ukrainian cities
captured on cctv this morning this is
the first time the eastern city of
dinipro has been hit
sky news has verified this video from
just before 6 a.m
there's no obvious military target here
this was a shoe factory
now it's embers and ash
cloaking what looks like the body of yet
another victim in a bloody war with ever
multiplying front lines
more than two million people have now
fled ukraine
those still here in besieged cities like
the northern kharkiv find shelter
wherever they can
an underground station now covered with
blankets phone chargers even a vase of
flowers as people just try to make the
surreal feel more bearable
i'm worried about my house my friends
houses and all of ukraine i'm worried
about very much and i'm scared what will
happen to me
as families cower in basements there's
the looming specter of chemical and
biological weapons attack and passionate
denials from ukraine that it has none
no chemical or any other weapons of mass
destruction were developed on my land
the whole world knows that
you know that
and if you do something like that
against us you will get the most severe
sanctions response
but russia claims the us has been making
biological weapons in ukrainian labs
it's convened the united nations
security council today to discuss but
boris johnson told sky news political
editor beth rigby that this is pure
strategy
the stuff that you're hearing about
uh chemical weapons this is straight out
of their playbook they start saying that
there are chemical weapons that have
been stored by uh their opponents or by
the americans and so when they
themselves deploy uh chemical weapons as
i as i fear they they may they have us a
a sort of a mask you're of cour a fake
story ready to go
a fake story with very real victims
humanitarian corridors are being tried
again today to help thousands escape
ravaged cities
where aid can't get in
and people can't get out
of totsi sky news
some breaking
lines to bring you now coming to us from
ukraine of course we've been keeping a
watching brief on any advances from
russian troops on the capital of kiev
well the mayor vitali klitschko has said
that he thinks that kiev has enough
vital supplies
to last for another couple of weeks he
thinks that there are still
around two million people who remain
in the city and his brother vladimir
says that some men and women who
initially fled the capital city are now
returning to kiev in preparation for a
fight with russian troops
now in the last hour the ukrainian
president has released a video message
online vladimir zolensky said that
ukraine had reached a strategic
strategic turning point in its war with
russia but cautioned that it was not
possible to say how long the fighting
would continue
for 16 days i know
many people are feeling tired now i
understand it
i understand
it's
all about emotions and
it's life when we mobilize our
efforts and when we see that
we can win
we expect
the enemy fall quicker but
the truth is this is the war this is the
fight we need more time we need more
patience
we need to be wise
we need
to do our job the best we can
to gain the victory we can't say how
many more days
we will need
to
take our land back but we can do it
because we want to do it we already have
strategic victory we're already on the
way to the victory this is our patriotic
war
they destroyed residential houses in
sumer region they continued torturing
mario paul
ivana frankevsk they targeted
this place as well
so they carry on their
invasion and that's why
we require further more rigid sanctions
against russia
because they
must pay for what they do
every day they must pay
european union has to do more
to implement a decision to do more for
ukraine for the european union
for
everyone all european nations expect
this to happen
[Music]
well let's have a look at all of the
latest movements that are taking place
on the ground in ukraine ali fortescue
is here to walk us through it
as we enter the third week of this
conflict general sir richard barrons is
with us he's been monitoring what's been
happening on the ground in ukraine let's
look first at kiev because we know that
russian advances are getting ever closer
this convoy that we saw has now
dispersed that we saw slowly getting
towards the capital
so over the last 10 days we've seen
russian forces advancing on care from
the north west and the north east
and now we're seeing two developments
one is the beginning to encircle more of
the city and secondly they're beginning
to get off the roads in the way that
that convoy was stuck for some time and
begin to deploy into battle positions
and that would indicate that the fight
for kiev is about to start
so kiev almost surrounded and if we look
at a closer map of the capital it's
worth saying this isn't going to be
straightforward is it for the russians
because this is
an urban area and fighting in a place
that is not just urban but as big as
kiev is very challenging
so by some distances with the biggest
fight so far in this war kiev is a city
of 2.8 million people originally three
times the size of manchester and as the
russians close up for on on a number of
routes towards the city their their
forces will be led by their their tanks
and their armored forces supported by
artillery and they're going to meet
stiff resistance from the ukrainian uh
military however as they reach the
outskirts of the built-up area they'll
transition that so the force is likely
to be led by infantry supported by an
awful lot of artillery and air power and
they'll meet really stiff ukrainian
resistance and the russians will start
to have to destroy large chunks of the
city to break in and this is where the
potential abhorrent question of chemical
weapons may arise because if the
russians are held up and they're stalled
or they fail
they may resort to chemical weapons to
try to unstick it with all the appalling
consequences that that would bring okay
and something of course that boris
johnson was warning about yesterday
let's talk um briefly about what's
happening northwest of the capital
embarrassiana because we have a
satellite image that shows what we think
are rocket launchers there tell us a bit
about this so this is a
assessed to be a very good example of
how the
the equipment that was on that road in
that convoy has begun to break out and
deploy that this is most likely six
rocket launchers they're 35 kilometers
from kiev right now
but they're in range of curve right now
so 35 kilometers away from the capital
and if we look at what is happening in
the rest of the country of course the
focus in the north is on kyo but in the
south where where should we be focusing
on so it's very important to look beyond
kiev although that remains the the the
big um main effort so in the south the
russian forces are fighting for mario
paul they've not taken it yet
but if they are successful they will
have achieved that strategic objective
of linking russia through mario pole to
the crimea
staying with the south the thing we're
expecting to see unfold
are russians moving west towards odessa
to complete the isolation of ukraine and
its economy from the sea
and then the last 24 hours have been uh
some interesting developments and de
nipro the first air attack which
suggests that perhaps after mariopol the
russians are going to close up to the
river wherever they can and then way
over in the west of ukraine air attacks
on a couple of airfields which are the
first time that's happened and that's
designed to
reduce the ability of the ukrainian air
force to operate and it's the first time
as you say we've seen attacks like this
this far west in ukraine it is indeed
thank you so much general sir richard
barrett thank you
well taking over the city of odessa as
we were hearing there in the south of
ukraine it's seen as one of russia's
next strategic goals sky's nick martin
says that the beaches of the city are
now being fortified by the civilians
there
the situation in odessa is there is now
as we've seen across ukraine the most
remarkable effort by civilians to try to
protect their beloved city here on the
south west coast of ukraine it is a
critical target for vladimir putin if he
is able to capture odessa he will be
able to cut off ukraine from the sea it
is a critical sea port and it is the
beaches that are now being fortified by
civilians to protect themselves from the
might of the russian army just have a
look at this in the summer by the way
they're sunbathing and fun on these
beaches today they're digging and
digging filling sandbag after sandbag to
try to protect these beaches it is the
most remarkable effort in the most
terrible chilling weather let's just
have a look around here the several
beaches across the coast here on the
southwest coast of ukraine
350
000
sandbags have been filled by these
people in the last two weeks alone while
they're doing that well they fear that
out there in the black sea there is a
build-up of russian military and navy
that have plans to try and mount some
kind of amphibious assault on the
beaches of odessa and the odessans are
not going to have any of it they say and
so these sandbags are going to be put
out across the coast here to try to
prevent that from happening
the president of ukraine vladimir
zelinski said that he has information
that the russians plan to attack odessa
just within the next few days and if
he's right then this
might might just be able to stave that
off but it's hard to see how that can be
possible just look at this effort a
human chain look at the weather it's
absolutely freezing cold and yet they're
still putting these sandbags on the back
of these lorries and moving them to
wherever they feel they can be uh be
beneficial now we do know that vladimir
putin has his sights set on odessa it's
the pearl of the black sea it's a hugely
strategic port and there's all sorts of
activity going on up and down this coast
but here right now i have to say that
it's quiet and you could say eerily
quiet but there is some intelligence to
suggest last week that the some russian
navy ships were spotted off the coast
it's a murky dark a murky windy day
today and you can't see any evidence of
that but what you can see is a huge
effort to try and fortify the beaches
here just behind me in normal times just
a few weeks ago this was a yacht club in
the summer people come here they have
fun they enjoy the coastline and now
look at it you know it's just the most
remarkable effort being played out in
front of us in the town they're building
barricades almost on every street the
cafes odessa's famous for its really
picturesque cafes i was here about five
years ago sitting having tea in the
square now it's completely deserted
those big steel blockades the hedgehogs
designed to stop tanks rolling through
the city they're almost on every corner
and there is a bit of a twitchiness in
the air
but here on the coast
the sandbags are really the key
but it just makes you wonder
just what and how effective they'll be
against the might of the russian
military who seem
really dead set on taking odessa uh it
really was the sort of jewel in the
crown of the soviet union
and vladimir putin has big ideas about
new russia and it would be hard to see
odessa not being a big part of that
and so they're doing all they can and
they're waiting uh for what might happen
in the next few days it's cold it's
windy it's snowy
but it's not putting them off
mcmartin there in odessa well let's take
a look at some of the key diplomatic
events that we're expecting to see today
or in just a moment we're going to be
bringing you an eu council news
conference that is taking place in
versailles in france the french
president emmanuel macron and the eu
commission president ursula fonda lyon
and the eu council president asham
michelle will be speaking after their
two-day summit on of course ukraine well
at three o'clock this afternoon the u.n
security council meets in new york at
russia's request to discuss what moscow
claims are the military biological
activities of the united states on the
territory of ukraine and at quarterback
three this afternoon president biden
will speak from the white house
announcing details of america's
continued response to the russian
invasion plenty to be keeping an eye on
there
well the uk has announced sanctions on
386 russian politicians who supported
vladimir putin's invasion of ukraine the
sanctions mean bans on travel to the uk
and also the freezing of assets for
those who voted for the independence of
separatist regions luhansk and also
donetsk
where we can go live now to westminster
and bring in our political correspondent
uh joe pike and turning up the heat it
would appear
joe but this is really something that
the eu did two two weeks ago
yeah there has been pretty consistent
criticism of the pace of the uk
sanctions effort in particular sanctions
on
individuals in this country or who could
travel to this country or of course have
assets in this country those are the
sanctions that will affect these 386
members of the duma the lower house of
the russian parliament who voted
to
recognize the independence of those two
breakaway
republics and now liz trust and her team
who have been criticized by labour for
not um sanctuary enough individuals now
say that their total list is 800 long
that is 800 companies individuals and
entities she's also said from washington
dc where she's meeting members of the
biden administration we will not let up
the pressure and we will continue to
tighten the screw
we're historically and and uh by nature
a a very very generous and uh open
welcoming people people want to work
people want to
well that was the number yesterday and
i'm it's rising the whole time and it
will rise
very sharply so you had to personally
intervene on uh on monday uh you'll get
from the
uh from from the leveling up secretary
uh you'll get uh the program that will
allow people to come in so people people
want to welcome it into their own homes
they can do so
another criticism of the government of
course being touched upon there by the
prime minister speaking to our political
editor beth rigby is how the uk's
responded on ukrainian refugees the pm
making it clear that on monday there
will be an announcement of a new scheme
that will facilitate uk nationals to
take in an individual or a family
there'll be a website to accompany it
but it is incredibly complex going to
understand there were meetings last
night with four different government
departments to lay out the details the
details are so important because we're
potentially talking about incredibly
vulnerable women and children who may
have had a traumatic journey to this
country but also may have seen some
pretty horrendous things in their own
country the government also need to work
out whether these people are entitled to
work whether they're entitled to
benefits and how long the uk uh national
uh receiving them needs to commit to is
it one month is it three months is it
six months but sam michael gove will
sell the details on monday
all right certainly one to be keeping an
eye on there joe thank you very much
indeed just want to bring you an update
coming to us from the un who has
confirmed 565
civilian deaths in ukraine while russian
forces
continue to advance on kiev while being
met with strong pushback from ukrainian
troops
joining me now is the ukrainian mp inner
substance who is in
the kiev region a very warm welcome to
you on sky news describe for us if you
would what you can see taking place
within the capital city well the
situation here is tense we don't know
whether the russians would actually be
able to get into the city it seems that
the ukrainian army is fighting back they
did manage to attack them on north east
direction and actually the russian
troops did have to surrender a bit
closer to the belarusian border uh which
does give hope to all of us uh but still
we know that they are not giving up and
they can try to gather forces and to
enter the city of kiev regardless of uh
two weeks of uh fruitless attempts to do
so so the situation in kiev despite much
much better than in cities like hakibo
particularly mariupol uh it's still
tense because we are we have seen what
they're doing to the cities where they
get into and that is indeed extremely
scary so we do have to trust our army
right now that they will actually manage
to keep them on the entrances to the
city and also the city itself has been
very strongly fortified so there are
checkpoints it's extremely difficult to
get into the city so that has given us
hope but of course we do see that the
level of cruelty by the russians is is
growing up so
well we have to to get ready for
anything to happen
the mayor of kiev says that he believes
that they have enough supplies to hold
out for two weeks
yes that seems to be what has been
happening in the past two weeks
the city has been getting prepared for
potential blockade or siege of course
the supply chains have been broken uh
and the main route from the west is now
located by the russians because they do
they did take control of that
road from the west but it seems like uh
well there is enough to survive
uh but of course that all depends on on
whether we shall be able to prevail and
the ukrainian army will manage to kick
them further from them from the capital
uh we again did see some success both in
kia we did see some success in hardkip
where they've been pushed further from
the city but of course those uh terrible
attacks from here is probably what is
most terrifying because what you are
seeing now on the picture now on the
video but those are the results of
attack from here and there is not much
ukrainian army can do unless we do get
some support in terms of protecting our
skies
mr klitschko also says that there are
two million people he believes still in
your capital city and his brother says
that actually people who initially fled
are coming back to try and help fortify
the city
uh
the situation is diverse indeed some
people did flee the city in different
period of times then many people who got
evacuated from the neighboring cities of
european and butcher they are all
actually getting located in the city as
of right now because uh trevor traveling
to the west is again complicated uh and
again in the cave city itself it does
seem to be much much uh safer because
the air defense is functioning much
better than in many other areas so
people are coming back uh we do see this
trend not just for the city of cuba for
ukraine overall we do know that since
the first day of war over 140 000 men
returned from abroad
to fight in the army or in the
territorial defense so this is a general
trend which we hope will help us save
them at least the capital city
and the humanitarian corridors don't
seem to be working have you any hope
that
they can work to get the people out who
want to leave
well they do work with different um
success i would say because clearly the
humanitarian corridor from the city of
maryland are not working every time the
russians are promising any type of
humanitarian corridor they are either
citing the land land mines there or they
open fire so as of right now people are
not even trying to get into a vacation
corridor from mariupol despite the
situation over there being tragic uh the
russians are bombarding the city from
here every 30 minutes and they're
combining not just the hospitals we have
seen they are combining the residential
area so i think that the city of
mariopol is now the biggest victim in
this russian aggression and they're
trying to arrange for a full-scale
blockade over there
as for other cities uh the evocation did
take place from the neighboring cities
of european buchanan
near kiev not from the first attempt we
did have many uh previous attempts where
the russians
opened fire on people trying to evacuate
people are advocating in extreme
conditions i did see pictures of people
evacuating by working on on the small
river uh in in in freezing weather
that's how they have to get out of of
the cities of erbin because then because
the the bridge was uh was destroyed over
there
uh but it seems like we did manage to
vacate uh some number of people uh
according to the recent data from the
ukrainian government about 50 000 people
have been evacuated but that's not
nearly nearly enough
of what
we need
and uh particularly in some distant
cities like in the summer it's extremely
difficult to get evacuated and the
russians are always trying to attack
those corridors so people are doing that
you know
it's a gamble for them on their life
and you know i want to ask you um there
are claims fears that uh russia may be
imminently
about to use chemical weapons on the
people
of ukraine what do people in
kiev think about that and how how long
how hopeful are you that you can hold
the capital city
well the chemical weapon is uh
is a big threat we are all extremely
concerned uh the ministry of health has
been disseminated information about what
you need to do you know in case of the
chemical attack uh we have another
threat because just about an hour ago
ukrainian intelligence
said that they have information that
russians might try to arrange for some
terrorist attack in the chernobyl
nuclear power station with their which
they are holding from the first day of
the attack
and that would be a threat not just to
the ukrainians there will be threat to
the whole of europe and that is why yeah
of course we are extremely terrified we
are terrified for our lives for the
lives of our loved ones
and and that is why we uh we really hope
that the west will intervene and uh help
us in that
in terms of securing the no-fly zone so
that we can you know continue fighting
on the ground and possibly pushing them
further into into their borders so that
they will not
attack with a chemical weapon and will
not think about arranging some sort of
terrorist attack on the nuclear power
station but the risk is real it's here
we we are going to bed every day
thinking about this and and this is
frankly speaking just terrifying
and in terms of what you want to see
coming from western nations you know i
mean it looks like that you know the the
uh the no-fly zone isn't going to happen
what realistically
do you think that you can get that you
really need
well we do need enough fly zone it
doesn't change because they are killing
us from air
they do have a superiority in the air
and uh they have disappeared because
they have much more airplanes but also
because they are abiding our civilian
population there is really very little
we can do in terms of uh helping our
people all over ukraine and they are
bombarding just random cities just this
morning we woke up to the news that they
bombarded
two cities in western ukraine where many
many people from the east have relocated
and then one city in in center east
ukraine and the city of nepal which is a
very big city in the central ukraine
so uh that is still what we need uh we
cannot really win in this war without
support from the air and that's why
we're asking for it so much because if
we have support from the air in any in
any way possible be it by giving us the
the fighter jets or giving us the air
defense system that we can operate
ourselves that would be a crucial help
that would actually give us a winning
chance in this terrible terrible war
that we are uh that putin launched
against us so so that is still the
primary issue in terms of securing uh
the lives of ukrainians because the
second big thing that we keep on asking
is is further uh sanctions because uh
the sanctions uh um and i've just heard
what you were reporting about the
personal sanctions we really hope that
they would have been uh
imposed way way earlier and we are happy
that now uh the united kingdom is
thinking about imposing the sanctions
against people who
voted to support the uh recognition of
those people's republic on the east of
ukraine but we are also asking to impose
personal sanctions again against their
family members because their children
cannot be studied in the united kingdom
right now that is not
how it should be their children should
be uh you know their visa should be
cancelled as well they should go back to
mother russia all their assets of their
children of their family members should
be frozen because we do know that
they're not really you know signing up
their own
bank accounts they have money on the
bank accounts on their of their family
members so we asking for individual
sanctions because we believe that people
who are responsible for what is
happening to us for killing ukrainians
for killing our children they need to
have some personal effect in their own
life uh be it uh inability to travel
frozen assets
uh their children not being able to
continue their education in the united
kingdom they should have some personal
consequences because right now those
consequences that uh there are for
russia overall
the people who are directly responsible
are not feeling them for themselves okay
uh really good of you to share your
thoughts with us um on sky news in the
softs and thank you very much thanks for
having me
well i made the refugee crisis a new
visa processing center will be set up in
the french city of aras for ukrainians
who are trying to come to britain well
laura bundock joins me now from that uh
that center and hello there laura you
found it at last
yeah it was a bit of a wild goose chase
because don't forget on monday it was
meant to be calais
then wednesday it was meant to be lille
which is about an hour away and today
friday it's arras now this is a a
government kind of local administrative
building here and this is where
via appointments only no walk-ins some
ukrainians will have help and be guided
through the visa application process as
i said it'll only be for people who are
referred here and only people deemed
eligible i.e at the moment people with
family in the uk but it has been
a pallava let's be honest getting to
this point um and
the reality is it's caused a lot more uh
disturbance upset for the ukrainian
families who thought they could get to
britain
relatively easy they heard about the
scheme with visas they knew they had the
family they had the correct
documentation in most cases but the
forms took forever all the forms are in
english so painful situations where it
took about an hour per person to fill
out a form to apply for the visa
then they had to go sought out biometric
testing the nearest centers
paris and brussels which is why this
pop-up one was set up that's all going
to be made easier from next week when
the virtual system comes into play but
it has been hard work and
you talk about centers moving from city
to city but the reality for people is
that the the people i met yesterday who
had been bust from calais to the
outskirts of lille to pretty grotty
accommodation many of whom have young
children they just want to get somewhere
safe now they've said goodbye to
husbands to their lives their jobs their
kids schools in ukraine their husbands
are fighting they want to get somewhere
safe for the short term i didn't meet
anyone who said they had a long-term
ambition to live in the uk i spoke to
one woman who was telling me doesn't
need money doesn't need benefits just
wants that family home she knows is
waiting for her they thought they'd be
in the uk by now but no they're still
here in france filling out the forms
waiting for reapproval before they can
then make the final bit of this huge
journey across to the uk
it goes on laura thank you
you're watching sky news coming up
president putin tells his belarusian
counterpart there are positive signs in
talks with ukraine
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back the russian president
vladimir putin has told his belarusian
counterpart that there are positive
signs in the talks taking place with
ukraine he was holding a security
council meeting this morning he spoke to
alexander lukashenko a little earlier
attempts to stem our development have
always been taken
and there are attempts to do this now on
a much larger scale of course and and
that's obvious but i'm confident that we
will overcome these difficulties and
will gain more competences more ability
to feel independent and self-sufficient
ultimately this will only be useful
just like in the previous years i will
of course update you about the situation
on ukraine and first of all on on the
course of negotiations that were that
are being conducted on a daily basis
there are some positive shifts as um i
was told by our negotiators on our side
i will let you know all the details in
the moment
and our moscow correspondent diana
magnay joins me now diana suggestions
today that moscow may bring in fighters
from the middle east
that's right uh president putin held a
meeting of his security council earlier
this morning and discussed bringing in
what he called um volunteers from the
middle east to
assist in the liberation which is the
way russia puts it of the people of
donbass and his defence minister sergey
shoigu said that there were already 16
000 of these volunteers
in syria and the middle east who had
suggested that they would want to come
and engage in the
fight or special military operation as
as russia likes to call it um and we
have seen some videos supposedly aired
from russia's ministry of defense of
people who are keen to join dmitry
peskov the kremlin spokesman was asked
in his daily call uh what exactly that
meant that
russia had to be sure that there weren't
any radicals amongst them
and he said there is a very big
difference between those who fought
radicals and those who are radicals and
it would clearly be those who fought
them
uh alexander lukachenko and vladimir
putin are meeting now um in the kremlin
uh interesting developments to tell you
though also about
meta which is of course the new name for
facebook um
overnight there were reports that um
meta had eased its policy in relation to
um
certain comments about uh the russian
armed forces that it was not blocked to
make pretty inflammatory comments about
the russian armed forces and that has
caused precipitated a very rapid
response from russia with the prosecutor
general demanding that the media
regulator block all metas platforms in
russia which is facebook instagram and
uh whatsapp um the prosecutor general
making that uh statement actually on
instagram which is pretty ironic but it
shows you how deep-rooted those networks
are in this country and is another
indication of really how much of a sort
of squeeze there is on the information
space you know here in moscow so much is
done on instagram you book everything on
instagram that will all go at a time
when you can really feel the sanctions
crunch uh coming in so you heard from
vladimir putin earlier that he feels
russia can weather the storm i think it
may take quite a while before uh
before we see you know the storm ending
diana thank you
now attempts are being made to help the
people who are trapped in the besieged
city of mariopol earlier the city's
deputy mayor told me that thousands of
people trapped in the city they're no
longer scared of the bombing because
they're just too desperate for food and
water
the situation is awful
russian army continues to do airstrikes
airborne
artillery shelling
and
their
troops are behind the city and in some
districts of the city we have war uh
street battles so as you understand the
humanitarian situation decrease our by
our second by second and ukrainian army
tries to defeat our city at the very
moment of course i should stand
optimistic and from our side from city
council and from the ukrainian part we
do our best to provide humanitarian
corridors so anyway we are ready to
transfer trucks with humanitarian goods
from the parisia to mariupol but it's
the seventh day of our attempt and
we do not find any solution because
trucks goes
some
some length and they stop over a russian
checkpoint and do not they do not allow
to go
to mariupol and as you know we are the
continuous
bombing and shelling exa directly in the
city and there is no any cease fire any
ceasefire this night we had eight
uh cases of airstrikes so they are
destroying all the city our by and
killing our civil people
reports from the u.s certainly believes
it's um its intelligence believes that
president putin may be about to use
chemical weapons on the people in
ukraine
what are the what are the feelings what
are the fears of people in mario paul
about that
you know uh
without any utility without connection
without everything for eight days they
do not know about this news anything
and you should know that um five to
seven days before
the best wish
of our people was to
stop somehow the war to stop bombing to
stop shelling
but today
and yesterday their best wish is to find
some food and water they even do not
afraid and scared about continuous
bombing and shell and then just want to
find some water and some food and
putting in his army does not allow to
provide any ceasefire and any
humanitarian medical social or any other
help for injured and
suffered people suffering people
during night there was eight different
airplanes that bombed the city and
flattened the city they absolutely
destroyed our biggest steel plant as of
style it does not exist anymore and they
are destroying all the buildings of the
district it's you should understand it's
an unmanaged bomb with one tone of truth
equivalent so the diameter of
after this bomb is 30 meter 40 meters so
they're destroying building by building
that's the deputy mayor of mario paul
speaking to me earlier on the program
you're watching sky news coming up
concerns about that putin may resort to
using chemical weapons in ukraine we'll
be discussing that after the break
[Music]
they push the protesters further back
here because around two or three hundred
still remain
i'm dan whitehead and i'm sky news's
west of england correspondent
[Music]
this fan goes on onto the streets of
plymouth seven days a week 365 days a
year these facilities are at the moment
a lifesaver
[Music]
from fishing communities to bustling
cities we spend every day reporting from
across the region hearing from people
who have real stories
i have nowhere to live for
about three or four months
there are still people inside the
properties here
they're coming from the epicentre of
what is now a global health pandemic
we were seeing and speaking to young
women who were selling themselves right
on the high street it was desperately
sad and the fact it was happening right
in the hearts of this community
before brexit these oysters were being
exported to the eu but the trade stopped
overnight
what's your feeling about the future
blake
i'd all be
finished i don't know
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now britain and america have accused
russia of lying in order to justify
carrying out a possible chemical attack
in ukraine moscow meanwhile has called
for an urgent meeting of the un security
council claiming without any evidence
that the u.s has been developing
biological weapons in ukraine
well andy weber was president obama's
assistant secretary of defense
responsible for nuclear chemical and
biological defense programs and he now
sits on the council of strategic risks
andy good to see you this afternoon can
we just start with the russian
allegations about u.s sponsored
biological warfare labs in ukraine
well these claims are not new actually
since about 15 years ago
through sort of kgb style disinformation
campaigns
media placements with bulgarian
journalists etc russia has been
promoting these claims but they've
escalated in the last
months and weeks
and even days to an official level where
the highest leaders even putin and
president xi in their joint statement
are making these outrageous false claims
and apparently they've called a meeting
of the u.n security council to to air
this propaganda today
but the u.s administration official has
said that has acknowledged the existence
of u.s funded biological research
facilities in the country
yes so i was
personally very involved in leading the
creation of this
partnership between ukraine and the
united states uh starting in 2005. we
worked with
ministry of health and ministry of
agriculture
public health and animal health
laboratories to improve ukraine's
ability to
detect diagnose and respond to
infectious disease outbreaks so think of
it as small
centers for disease control type
laboratories that are totally
transparent do peaceful work uh peaceful
research to
for example to counter the covet
pandemic it's an extremely useful effort
and do you have collaborations like that
with many countries around the world
yes as a matter of fact over 30
countries are working with the us
department of defense to create what we
call an early warning network
for infectious disease outbreaks so we
can nip them in the butt at the source
before they spread around the world and
become a pandemic
do you agree with the assessment andy
that u.s intelligence is suggesting and
the uk prime minister is also
fearful of potentially an imminent
chemical weapons attack on the people of
ukraine from russia
yes i think it is a grave concern that
russia like its ally
syria could use
either chemical
or biological weapons against civilians
in ukraine and then just as
president assad in syria did blame it on
ukraine so we call this a false flag
attack and i think that's one
explanation of why they're ramping up
their insidious propaganda campaign
um i know that you uh you were part of
the obama administration at the time uh
chemical weapons the use of in syria was
declared as the red line
beyond which nobody could go and i know
that you were responsible for uh dealing
with the decommissioning of chemical
weapons in syria but was it a mistake to
have not just instigated airstrikes at
the time because people are saying that
that lack of military response has
resulted in leaders like putin thinking
that they can use chemical weapons with
impunity
well i strongly disagree with that it
was part of an effort a multinational
effort with the uk the united nations to
safely
remove and destroy 1
300 tons of chemical weapons agents from
syria um including horrible agents like
vx and sarin so that's 1 300 tons that
the regime can't use against its
neighbors and against its own uh
men women and children like they did in
august of 2013 on the sub in ghouta
outside of damascus so that was a very
successful operation um
without um firing a shot it would have
been very hard to do that uh in
impossible actually to do that in some
type of a military attack
but do you know but by declaring it a
red line and then not instigating the
airstrikes which there was there were a
number of countries calling for it
has that not weakened our credibility do
you think in the eyes of vladimir putin
well who knows in the head of vladimir
putin anything is possible especially in
his current uh
desperate state as as the war that he uh
started is not going very well
but actually the red line worked we
successfully using the threat of
military force were able to denude syria
of its enormous and very dangerous
chemical weapons stockpile yeah but here
we are talking about potentially an
imminent chemical weapon attack um
instigated by russia on ukraine
well russia's a country that used uh
very advanced chemical weapons in
peacetime
in salisbury england so
and and more recently against navalny
inside russia so i think this is a very
realistic concern
that they might use chemical weapons in
the current uh
war against ukraine
and uh blame it on the united states or
uh ukrainians but it's uh it's absurd
it's desperate and we need to
be very uh frank and open in public that
their charges of of illicit biological
weapons labs in ukraine are just
poppycock and andy do you know
about what russia has been stockpiling
in terms of its chemical weapons if
there is an attack do we know what it
would look like what would they use
well the soviet union had the world's
largest chemical weapons and biological
weapons program in total violation of
the chemical and biological weapons
conventions these weapons are prohibited
so they could use
advanced chemical weapons like novichok
vx
sarin
in attacks to
to terrorize the public
to clear buildings
they could also use
more
available things like chlorine gas
as in terms of biological weapons i
think they're less likely to use
something that's contagious that spreads
human to human because that could spread
back into russia so they're more likely
to use something that doesn't spread
human to human like anthrax which has
tremendous okay
andy webber i'm really sorry to cut you
off but we are out of time thank you for
your time on sky news thank you samantha
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
you